>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO >> Jesse: DOME XP
23.
IF YOU EVER HAD KIDS IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL, YOU KNOW WHAT SUSTAINED
EMOTIONAL DRAMA LOOKS LIKE.
EVERYTHING IS REALLY PLACID UP
UNTIL ABOUT SEVENTH GRADE, THAN
THE FOUR HORSEMEN OF THE
ADOLESCENT APOCALYPSE ARRIVE.
HORMONES, HOMEWORK.
THE MAIN SYMPTOM IS WILD
OVERSTATEMENT.
NO LONGER IS ANYTHING OKAY OR
NOT VERY GOOD, NO, EVEN THE
MILDEST INCONVENIENCE IS
TRANSFORMED INTO A HORRIFYING
WORLD AND A DISASTER.
THE TITANIC PLUS Y2K.
4 MINUTES LATE FOR SCHOOL IS THE
SINGLE WORST THING OF MY LIFE,
EVER.
WAKING UP BEFORE 9:00 A.M. IS
LIKE DEATH.
A POP QUIZ IN MATH CLASS?
THAT IS THE EMOTIONAL EQUIVALENT
OF ETHNIC CLEANSING IN BOSNIA.
THANKFULLY MOST KIDS GET OVER
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
THOSE WHO DON'T TEND TO LEAVE
HOME AND NOT COME BACK.
THEY BECOME INTERPRETIVE DANCE
MAJORS AT THE SMALL LIBERAL ARTS
COLLEGES OR RUN FOR CONGRESS.
EVER WONDER WHY AMERICA'S
TRADITIONAL PARTY OF THE
UNIONIZED WORKINGMAN SUDDENLY
SOUNDS LIKE A VAN FULL OF
EIGHTH-GRADE GIRLS ON THE WAY TO
PROM ON THE URGE DOME ON VERGE
OF TEARS?
AT THIS POINT, THAT IS PRETTY
MUCH EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS.
YOU REALLY NOTICE IT IN THE WAY
THEY SPEAK.
FOR DEMOCRATS, THERE ARE NO MORE
SMALL PROBLEMS.
NO CHALLENGES MINOR.
EVERY SPEED BUMP IS A FULL-BLOWN
CATASTROPHE.
EVERY DISAGREEMENT, TOTAL WAR.
LOSING AN ELECTION?
THEY CAN EVEN TALK ABOUT IT.
CLOSE YOUR EYES AND TRY TO
PICTURE THE SCARIEST THREAT YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
THE PROWLER AT THE DOOR, THE
MONSTER UNDER THE BED, AN IRS
AUDIT.
NOW MULTIPLY THAT SEEN BY
1 MILLION SWEAT COVERED
NIGHTMARES AND YOU ARE JUST
BEGINNING TO APPROACH THE LEVEL
OF TERROR THE DEMOCRATS FEEL
WHEN THEY THINK ABOUT GIVING UP
POWER.
IT'S NOT JUST A BAD OUTCOME, IT
IS THE END OF DEMOCRACY.
WATCH.
>> IT'S THE END OF OUR DEMOCRACY
INSIDE?
>> I BELIEVE THE ELECTION OF
JOE BIDEN ESSENTIALLY PAUSED OUR
DISSENT INTO THE COMPLETE
UPENDING OF OUR DEMOCRACY, BUT
WE ARE NOT OUT OF IT.
>> IT'S THE END OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> WE MIGHT SEE THE END OF
DEMOCRACY IN THE COMING YEARS.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING IT'S STILL
POSSIBLE WE COULD LOSE OUR
DEMOCRACY HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
IF AMERICANS LOSE FAITH IN THE
HONOR OF OUR ELECTIONS, IT IS
THE BEGINNING OF THE END OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
TO SPEAK I THINK THAT COULD BE
THE END OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
NOT TO BE TOO POIGNANT ABOUT IT,
BUT I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND.
>> HILLARY CLINTON SAID IT COULD
BE AND OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
YOU SHOULD NOT FEAR?
>> I DO.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE OVERLY
ALARMIST, BUT I THINK WE SHOULD
BE ALARMED.
THIS COULD BE THE END OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY AND I NEVER
THOUGHT I BE SAYING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
>> Tucker: "IT COULD BE THE
END OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY."
WE ALWAYS KNEW THAT MAX BOOT
LOVED TO KILL BROWN PEOPLE IN
FARAWAY COUNTRIES OR SEND OTHER
PEOPLE'S KIDS TO DO IT FOR HIM.
WE HAD NO IDEA THAT MAX PRUDEN
WAS IN THE IDEA OF A FULL BLOWN
EMOTIONAL BREAKDOWN.
HOW ELSE TO EXPLAIN A REACTION
LIKE THAT?
FOR A WELL-ADJUSTED NORMAL
PERSON, UNWANTED ELECTION
OUTCOMES ARE PART OF LIFE.
VOTERS DON'T ALWAYS DO WHAT YOU
WANT THEM TO DO.
IT IS FRUSTRATING, BUT THAT IS
HOW IT WORKS.
IN FACT, WHEN VOTERS REJECT YOU
YOU GET A CHANCE TO ASSESS YOUR
OWN BEHAVIOR.
CHANCES ARE THERE IS A REASON
THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T WANT YOU IN
POWER AND YOU KNOW HAVE TIME TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT REASON
MIGHT BE.
THAT IS A HEALTHY PROCESS.
SO WHEN YOU LOSE, IT IS HARDLY
PROOF THAT THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
IN FACT, IT'S USUALLY EVIDENT
THAT THINGS ARE WORKING EXACTLY
AS INTENDED.
BUT PEOPLE LIKE MAX BOOT AND LIZ
CHENEY DO NOT SEE IT THAT WAY.
THEY ARE TOO FRAGILE TO FACE
THEIR OWN UNPOPULARITY.
TO PEOPLE LIKE THAT, THE
PROSPECT OF REJECTION BY VOTERS
OF LOSING CONTROL OF THE COUNTRY
MEANS LITERALLY, LITERALLY THE
END OF DEMOCRACY ITSELF.
IMAGINE FEELING THAT WAY.
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT YOUR
ELECTION LAWS MEANT THE END OF
AMERICA AND THE BEGINNING OF A
THOUSAND YEARS OF DARKNESS, YOU
MIGHT HAVE TROUBLE KEEPING
PERSPECTIVE ON POLITICS.
EVERY ELECTION WOULD FEEL LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND IF YOUR SIDE OF HER LOST AN
ELECTION, HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE A
DISASTER AFTER THAT?
WORDS WOULD FAIL YOU, YOU WOULD
HAVE ONLY ANIMAL SOUNDS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
[BILLING]
[BOOING]
>> Tucker: NO!
SOMEONE YOU DIDN'T VOTE FOR OR
WON PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IF YOU ARE NOT A DEMOCRAT, IT'S
PRETTY HARD TO IMAGINE THE PAIN
OF A MOMENT LIKE THAT.
FOR DEMOCRATS IT WAS LIKE BEING
BOILED ALIVE IN A GIANT MUG OF
THE WORLD'S HOTTEST LATTE,
WITHOUT THE PHONE.
FOUR YEARS OF RETCHING AGONY.
DEMOCRATS INEVITABLY CAME TO THE
OBVIOUS CONCLUSION.
GOING FORWARD NO VOTER ALIVE OR
DEAD, CITIZEN OR LEGAL, SHOULD
EVER AGAIN BE ASKED TO SHOW
VOTER I.D. AT THE POLLS.
IT WAS A SIMPLE, ELEGANT
SOLUTION THAT NO SENSIBLE PERSON
COULD DISAGREE WITH.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERYONE IS
SENSIBLE.
MANY PEOPLE ARE LIKE HITLER, SO
THEY OPPOSED VOTER FRAUD.
DEMOCRATS WASTED NO TIME IN
BECOMING HYSTERICAL ABOUT THIS.
WATCH.
>> TONIGHT'S LEAD, JIM CROW 2.0.
>> IT IS THE MOST PERNICIOUS
THING -- THIS MAKES JIM CROW
LOOK LIKE JIM EAGLE.
>> OUR REMANENCE OF JIM CROW --
I SHOULDN'T EVEN SAY REMANENCE,
REVIVALS.
AN ATTEMPTED REVIVAL.
>> A JIM CROW KKK LIKE CAUCUS.
>> THEIR STRATEGY IS TO
EFFECTIVELY BRING BACK JIM CROW
IN THE SOUTH AND ALLOW
REPUBLICANS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO IMPLEMENT JIM CROW
2.0.
>> JIM CROWE AT 2.0.
THIS IS SALLY AND EVERY OTHER
CROW THAT WE COULD IMAGINE.
>> Tucker: ITS VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
IT IS THE NEW JIM CROW.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
A SHOWING PHOTO I.D. TO VOTES
--THAT IS BOTH JIM CROW AND JAE
CROWE AND FOR THAT MATTER --
THAT IS HOW IMMORAL VOTER IDEAS
BUT IT'S A STOP AT RIGHT, SAYS
ERIC MICHAEL DYSON.
AT THIS POINT, A LOT OF THINGS
ARE THE END OF DEMOCRACY
INCLUDING WE ARE HERE TO TELL
YOU NOT WEARING A MASK AND AN
ELEVATOR.
YES.
THAT IS THE END OF DEMOCRACY TOO
SAYS THE LATEST BULLETIN.
WE ARE NOT ACCUSING ANYONE OF A
STEREO, WE ARE JUST REPORTING
THE NEWS, FROM THIS CITY
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN.
IN ANY CASE, HERE SHE IS
EXPLAINING THE LATEST THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
>> THIS HAS HAPPENED TO ME WHERE
YOU GET ON AN ELEVATOR AND
PEOPLE REFUSE TO WEAR A MASK AND
YOUR CHOICES ARE TO EITHER GET
OFF THE ELEVATOR OR TO GET ON
THE ELEVATOR AND TO TELL THEM TO
WEAR A MASK.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE A PROBLEM IN
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO REFUSED TO EVEN
ADHERE TO THE BASIC NORMS OF
STABILITY ARE UNDERMINING OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OF COURSE WE ARE
SEEING IT IN AN EVEN MORE
SERIOUS WAY.
LIKE THE JANUARY 6 INSURRECTION.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, THE
OTHER CHOICES TO SEEK IMMEDIATE
PSYCHIATRIC CARE AND BEHAVE LIKE
AN ADULT.
THAT IS NOT OCCUR TO THEM.
BECAUSE DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
TURNS OUT YOU CAN JUST DRY OUR
ANCIENT DEMOCRACY BY FORGETTING
TO WEAR YOUR MASK AND AN
ELEVATOR.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MOMENT,
OUR DEMOCRACY IS THAT BRITTLE.
ONE ACT OF CARELESSNESS AND IT
COULD SHATTER INTO A MILLION
PIECES LIKE A PRICELESS BASE.
IT'S ENOUGH TO KEEP YOU UP AND T
NIGHT.
THEY THOUGHT THAT SOME OAF MIGHT
TRIP ON A CARPET EDGE AND DROP
DEMOCRACY ONTO A HARDWOOD FLOOR,
LITERALLY, LITERALLY MAKES
ADAM KINZINGER CRY.
HOW SENSITIVE HE HAS.
WATCH.
>> I NEVER EXPECTED A DAY TO BE
QUITE AS EMOTIONAL FOR ME AS IT
HAS BEEN.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THAT DAY...
[INDISTINCT]
DEMOCRACIES ARE NOT DEFINED BY
OUR BAD DAYS.
WE ARE DEFINED BY HOW WE COME
BACK FROM BAD DAYS.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER
SEVENTH-GRADE GIRL REPRESENTING
YOU IN CONGRESS, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
MR. ADAM KINZINGER.
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER IF WE WOU